you have to like do that like twisted i
just put it oh my goodness
[Music]
hey guys i'm tristan i'm rui he does
most of the cooking
i do a lot of the cleaning especially in
the kitchen after i cook the meal i'm
exhausted right so then i leave the
kitchen in a mess and then she gets mad
at me for this challenge you're going to
be
swapping kitchen rolls in this ultimate
battle of
cook versus cleaner rui you'll have
access to the sink
soap and sponge towels ultra pro to help
you clean as
tristan cooks on the menu tonight is
a classic spaghetti and meatballs with
caesar salad
i love it all right
full start on the meatballs ground beef
ground pork one pound
any egg shells in there no no i'm so
good at cracking eggs rui pepper flakes
because we
need some spice ree you like pepper
right oh you always add too much
okay go ahead do whatever it's too spicy
okay you need some spice in your life
is this asmr okay let's get the mic real
close
oh my gosh oh how much time do we have
what in the world okay give me another
onion quick quick chop chop let's go
there's onions
i need garlic the onions right there oh
my god and you need garlic okay
you still made a mess you said you
wouldn't make a mess okay
all right rui i have a gift for you a
dirty pan
some chili flakes
[Music]
oh that's beautiful oh more pepper
yeah that's fine what oh now look who's
busy
yes yes yes yes yes
there's a lot of chili um it'll be fine
time truck please oh gosh
we're not looking good for time but the
meatballs are looking good
ruby there's a bit of a mess on the
counter okay i will
take care of that immediately you have
to like do that like twist i just
put it on oh my goodness perfect look at
that that is beautiful time check
three minutes three minutes uh-oh let's
pass the ball in three minutes
why don't you throw it against the wall
see if it sticks
i want to do it fancy like they do at
the restaurant
okay perfect time we are done we did it
all right let's try
oh that's some giant meatballs all right
i am going to judge your work let's see
how well you clean the kitchen
go ahead sinks are
pretty good counters that's pretty good
i don't feel anything
hmm there seems to be a speck of pepper
we are going to be rating each other's
work on a scale of
one to ten one two three three
oh i got the same thing okay i took off
0.5 for that flake of pepper
and i took off 0.5 for too much pepper
it's a little squishy it's a little bit
spicy we did it
you